26% increase in GDP in 2015 I mean who
knows what this does to GDP per capita
because of course a lot of this is being
influenced by companies inverting into
islands their profits they look as
exactly being created in that Irish
economy and actually they're not really
like no I mean the sad part of that is
is that a lot of the companies that that
have moved in that creating this great
don't actually employ very many people
and I'm so that's that's the sad thing
but even even so the market is another
estimate a ssin for that GDP figure was
I think a 7.8 percent that's a pretty
strong forecast the 26 percent is just
out of this world but I do think that
last year I think I'm right in saying
that that island still had the strongest
growth rate in the developed world as
well at least one of those so it has
been doing pretty well it has been doing
well they've got a low tax rate which is
perhaps what George Osmond was
channelling but then this brings us back
to you a much bigger perhaps non FX
question which is the disparity in
wealth yeah in other words it is
corporate wealth which has been
delivered it is the rich who are getting
richer it's one of the most read stories
on Bloomberg this one is yes it's the
baby boomers they're getting wealthier
and this is what politicians have got to
deal with and we did see backlash to
that in the most recent election because
we did see the Taoiseach up he has
remained in power but he didn't get the
support that he thought would at the
election and the reason for that is the
same reason that you're seeing
participates across Europe and in the
u.s. too people still feel disgruntled
people in Ireland still feel that they
cannot afford housing real people
haven't acceded to any wealth tonight
yes I see so for that reason there is
still an awful lot of work to be done in
terms of reform and you could say that
all of these stock market gains well who
owns those assets wealthy people and
again this doesn't help